vous m'entendez série est ce que le sont
pas c'est ce que le duplex se passe idée
qu'elle est bonne et les mecs en tirer
est ce que vous entendez vous allez
julien ouais tu la wii wheel et bakary
l'île de la tentation mais on dirait
qu'on appelle des mecs c'est lille celi
le doigt de télé et de la déportation au
regard des bonnes équipes devaient
regarder l'équipe franchement nous
sommes arrivés en bateau là on va se
mettre debout à la demande des soldats
français
alors l'ailé l'autre côté français - six
soldats civils oui mais chéri mes chiens
on est de l'autre côté de france 2 ça va
lâcher à tout
alors au nom on est en train de donner
coachella
s'il vous plaît monsieur vous êtes un
fait non la magie est ce que vous pouvez
les sédentaires civile a mené au touché
150 tonnes au mariage et non